so just yesterday mayor garcetti from la
announced that he's given
24 million dollars anti-poverty program
would give
cash to la residents this is how it
works out you have to have been affected
by covid
you have to be somebody that is making
below or
at poverty level income and you have to
be having a kid that's under the age of
18.
but i want to break you down today with
you we'll read the whole article from
newsweek
then i'm going to give you stats on
homelessness and whether this is a good
idea or a bad idea
and is it a thing that's going to
attract the right kind of people to the
city of la
and even to the state of california so
let's get right into it
so here's the article from la that came
out newsweek gets a little bit more
detailed into it says
mayor guard said it flows a thousand
dollar a month basic uh universal basic
income making la the 12th
u.s location to try this so let's go a
little bit deeper with this article
thousand dollars a month to poor local
families for one year similar proposals
have been tried in at least 12 different
cities since 1968
and also gaining interest amongst other
u.s mayors garcetti's proposal would
allocate 24 million
of the city's budget towards a program
called the big
leap an acronym for basic income
guaranteed la economic assistance pilot
the program will give two thousand
dollars we already read that uh
the families could then spend the cash
however they please garcetti said he
hopes the program could provide a model
for
similar anti-poverty initiatives in
other cities
this is him saying we have to end
america's addiction to poverty i don't
know what he
means by that meaning like we're
addicted to having more poor people
or that people are addicted to being
poor there's a couple different ways you
can interpret that
statement with for families who can't
think past the next bill
the next shift the next health program
that they have we can give them the
space to not only dream of a better life
but to actualize it
similar programs have been floated in at
least four other la city districts
according to la
garcia's program would be the 12th since
1982 alaska has given its citizens
an annual check ranging one thousand to
two thousand dollars
the money comes from the alaska
permanent fund a state-owned investment
fund
financed by states oil revenue and this
is different because you have to keep in
mind that a lot of my friends who were
at
fort wainwright which is in alaska they
used to get that check
it's a way of keeping citizens because
most people don't want to move to alaska
so they want to retain them they want to
keep them
and since they have the resources they
can afford to do that doesn't affect the
city or the state that much in 1997 the
eastern band of cherokee indian
casino dividend in north carolina has
given every tribe member an annual check
of 46 000
the money comes from a casino that
operates on tribal land fair enough
you're
operating on the tribal land from 1968
to 1974 various
u.s cities and regions have given basic
incomes to approximately
7 500 people the regions that have
included denver colorado
gary indiana seattle washington iowa
jersey carolina pennsylvania according
to vox
keep these names in mind because we're
going to look at some of the
homelessness numbers
in the states to see what this looks
like obviously this started off with
2020 presidential candidate
andrew yang promoted the freedom
dividend a monthly thousand dollar check
that would be sent to everybody he even
tested it out with a couple of people
himself
sending money himself anyways so let's
look at
a couple things a number to look at here
this is an article from ktla again about
the pilot program that's being tested
mike arnold who's the presidency of
midnight mission which provides beds
meals and drug
rehabilitation services on skid row
which we've been many times calls the
proposal great news
but worried the dollars would taper off
after one year let's take a look at this
arnold points to new york city which has
roughly the same number of homelessness
residents as la and spends about a
billion dollars a year to address this
crisis
currently only about 25 of la county's
66 000 homeless residents are benefiting
from the available resources fine
if we look at the data from security.org
this is a recent article
of 10 days ago state of homelessness and
2021 statistics analysis and trends i'm
going to put the link below for you to
read because
this is fantastic data that's educating
us of where we are
today right it's telling you that
homelessness from fi you know 2016 we
had 549
2020 we had 580 and this year were well
over 600 because of uh
what happened with kovit but if you go
lower here
this shows homelessness people per
hundred thousand
by state look who's at the top dc
898 per hundred thousand
new york 464. hawaii
453 california 406. oregon
345. have you noticed the trend here
washington 299
alaska 264. all of these guys
not all of them but alaska tried it
washington tried it oregon california
new york the dividend program to give
homeless people incomes right they've
tried it
and their homelessness keeps increasing
nevada vermont colorado
you know new mexico maine arizona so you
look at this data and you're like okay
why are these states having higher
homelessness
than other states then if you go lower
and you look at some of the states that
are
decreasing on the ranking you'll notice
that california
is where california at california keeps
increasing 6.2 percent
new york is decreasing this could be
because during covid
homeless folks may be left because it's
colder i don't know florida is
decreasing
3.5 at the top is arkansas 13.4 percent
that it's decreasing again this is great
data to look at if we come to the top
cities of homelessness that are above
the national average look what state
you'll see
on most of them santa cruz california
santa maria california
that's santa barbara one of the
wealthiest cities
in america san luis obispo right by mora
bay it's a beautiful place
uh california honolulu hawaii santa
barbara
california san francisco california five
out of the top six
california seattle washington
springfield
massachusetts sacramento california fort
pierce florida which is
south of melbourne i believe and north
of uh i want to say
jupiter palm beach that's where fort
pierce is at and again it's a warm area
so people want to go there
anchorage alaska then you got vallejo
california
portland oregon myrtle beach south
carolina san diego
california amarillo texas
amarillo texas albany new york oxnard
california you get the idea here i don't
want to bore you to that how many
californians you see california
california california california
oregon new york california california
california you see the numbers here
this is non-stop okay so if you want to
come back to me here uh while we're
looking at this
so what does this mean is this a good
idea this is a bad idea a couple things
i want you to be thinking about
when it comes down to government what is
the role of a government and what kind
of a
when i say government it could be city
state and countries right
what role do governments play in
attracting
people and what types of people you have
incentives
you have where you punish let me explain
if you punish
entrepreneurs way too much they go to a
different state
if you punish criminals too much maybe
people come to want to raise their
families there because they feel safer
if you punish job creators they leave
incentive if you incentivize job
creators
they come to you if you incentivize
homeless people
they come to you if you incent this the
whole idea is
whatever the incentive is you get that
whatever the punishment is you lose that
so
la in this situation is saying a
thousand dollars a month to
2000 families criteria
you have to be at or living below
poverty level kid under the age of 18n
you were affected by covid which is not
gonna be only two thousand it's gonna be
a lot of them so a lot of people are
gonna be left behind but it's a test to
see how this that's what 24 million
bucks and then what do you do do you go
to 48 million 100 million 200 million
because
the reality of it la what limit do you
have
it's 24 million enough so now the debate
becomes that's nothing we need more so
we go 15 that's nothing we need more
hundred
that's nothing when still billion that's
nothing so it's always going to be
that's nothing we need more that's
nothing we need more until eventually
the city and the state goes bankrupt
that's kind of how everything works out
right on family
when when i started making money my
first time around
i got calls hey pat hey man i hear
you're killing it can i have lunch with
you
no problem hey bro i'm really going
through tough times man you mind just
you know but lending me a thousand
dollars oh shoot i feel
absolutely bro here you go hey man you
don't understand i'm going through
really tough times or do you mind
lending me 500
yeah i'll give it back to 500 200 800
700 this kept happening and then my dad
when they sat man i trust pat what are
you doing he says you realize
every time you keep giving money away
word of mouth is
call pat he's giving money away you're
inviting
people to keep calling you to ask for
money but here's the problem pat i said
what's that
the moment you stop paying those people
you paid
as much as they like you they turn on
you like this and they'll become your
biggest enemies
he says if you don't get from the
beginning at least you manage the
expectation and they say
don't go to pat he's just not going to
give you anything but it's cool you
understand how this thing works out
right with the states
so california is essentially saying come
on down we'll give money away to you
all they're doing is they're putting the
target on their backs because imagine
how many other people in america are
struggling they're saying
let me tell you something man
california's doing this california's
doing this let's get a one-way ground
i'll do it let's get a one-way ground
let's go to l.a let's go to l.a let's go
to l.a
homelessness keeps coming into l.a so
folks in la if you're watching this
i am not telling you it's a good thing
it's a bad thing here's what i'm telling
you
i think the people need to take up
their own responsibility not relying on
the government to do it
i think people need to figure out a way
how to address this issue
not just relying on the government we
did this every christmas for
eight nine years four four fifty in the
morning four thirty in the morning we'd
get up everybody would you get to get
out our office and we'd go
join a group of people at skid row and
we'd give away 500 whoppers 500 burgers
or we'd give away
you know food bibles shirts sweaters
blanket toothpaste toothbrush
and it would be hundreds of people
showing up and we would do this
regularly throughout the year
now is that enough to put a dent into it
it's not the real dent is to create jobs
to get people to be self-sufficient
all i'm saying to you right now is the
more and more california comes with pro
exam
programs like this they become a magnet
of people who need exactly
what california la is offering those
cities
are going to get more people wanting to
move to l.a
so essentially homelessness after this
announcement
is probably going to increase even more
than what it is today
in the great city in the great city of
la that i lived in for 24 years it's
going to increase in the great
city of l.a i want to hear your thoughts
agree or disagree comment below if you
agree put thumbs up if you disagree put
thumbs down
i want to hear your thoughts and if
you've not seen a video that's done
on what is really taking place in
california we talked about this on one
of the podcasts
if you've not seen it click over here to
go watch the video
on others in la this was a video that
was in september of last year talking
about the challenges taking place
in la with homelessness having said that
have a great day everybody take care bye